[Music]
okay so I said if Chris comes tonight we
don't have a baby yet so you came so
we're waiting stuff yeah no no baby yet
you know if you're correct how is
everything going
how about tea very the thing I said I
saw you on the list I wrote my questions
and I said if she comes we're not at the
hospital there you go
are you ready do you feel ready are you
excited for the world was she ready you
know she makes I think so so we'll see
she's got a little bit huh you give her
advice I give her so much advice she's
sick of me yeah we all give her advice
because you know most of us have had a
child or two in this family so yeah
we're just I mean when you have your
first baby you're scared yep while Khloe
Kardashian gets closer and closer to her
due date it's business as usual for the
rest of the famous family et spoke with
momager Kris Jenner on Sunday at the
daily front rose fourth annual fashion
Los Angeles Awards where she honored her
longtime hairstylist and friend Jen
Atkins
she's the hardest-working person I know
in my life next to me she's an
entrepreneur at such a young age and
she's so inclusive so I'm proud of her
[Music]
[Applause]